Let's go next to our friend Don Tay from Florida.
Don t from Florida.
What's what do you have for me today, Don?
Hey, hey.
There was actually Don tell Don Telephone's
border.
OK.
I we always had you as don t and I stand corrected.
Don tell.
We will update it in the system.
Ah.
So there's a lot of groupthink around what
the left should do, go forward and only talk
about that for a little bit.
So like in the 2020 election, the there is
this idea that people who agreed with Bernie
Sanders place on his party platform that.
The the best option that they have to see
those being implemented would be to support
your baby.
And I just don't think that's true alchemy
is any evidence for this shrew.
The best way to see those policies implemented
would be to.
Organize and try to pressure congressional
leadership and to pressure Donald Trump into
implementing.
So I do you second, Don, tell I want to make
sure I understand and try to keep the phone
a little further from your mouth because you're
coming in very hot and we're having a hard
time modulating you.
So it sounds like you're sort of setting up
a let me let me inquire.
Are you setting up a false choice or are you
actually saying that Trump as president and
pressuring him will be better than Biden being
president?
Are you actually saying it would be better
for Trump to be president and to pressure
Trump rather than for Biden to be president
and to pressure Biden?
That's the word I'm looking at, all of being
into that.
You're not going to push Joe Biden to the
left.
You're not going to push him to the left to
the point where you get Medicare for all.
And the thing with Donald Trump going, where
are you going to get Medicare for all is to
force their hand to pressure them with protest
and calling them out.
Did the Democratic leadership.
There are other ways to do it on my part.
But the Sunrise movement.
They organized.
Sit in and think about one second.
Don't tell.
Let me make sure, because the first assertion
you made, unless I misunderstood, was rather
you disagree that electing Joe Biden is the
way to get progressive stuff done.
You said that congressional leaders should
pressure Trump.
But then you said neither Joe Guy.
All that was taken down to a whole lot of
the low.
Hold on.
If we're not, we're not gonna be able to talk
unless you I have to be able to tell you what
I heard.
And then you can correct it.
OK.
You first said you disagree with what you
called group think on the left that Joe Biden
is the best way to get Bernie Sanders policies
passed.
You then said, I believe we are better off
having congressional leaders pressure Trump.
I then asked, are you saying you would rather
Trump than Biden because you think we can
get more from Trump?
You then said no.
What I'm saying is either way, we're not getting
Medicare for all.
So how is it that we're going to if either
way we're not getting Medicare for all, how
will we get it by pressuring Trump to give
it to us?
I didn't see either way would I be doing Medicare
for all.
You literally did not have any idea where
I'm going to trust Joe Biden to the left.
We're not going to push Joe Biden to the left.
No, that's not what you said.
Until you can go back and listen to what you
said.
Specifically, we're not going to push back
Biden to the left to support war.
Oh, yes, right.
Or they just said you aren't we aren't going
to be able to get either of them to do it.
But you open them to the left.
All right.
We're not going to do it.
It's impossible to have a conversation like
this, Don.
I'm sorry, cop.
Call back a different day and we'll we'll
try to start up again.
Go listen to the call and you'll see exactly
what you said.